so in the last video I talked about
three-dimensional vector fields and I
finish things off with this sort of
identity function example where at an
input input point XYZ the output vector
is also XYZ and here I want to go
through a slightly more intricate
example so I'll go ahead and get rid of
this vector field and in this example
the X component of the output will be Y
times Z the Y component of the output
will be x times Z and the Z component of
the output will be x times y so we'll
just show this vector field and then we
can start to get a feel for how the
function that I just wrote relates to
the vectors that you're seeing so you
see some of the vectors are kind of
pointing away from the origin some of
them are pointing in towards the origin
so how can we understand this vector
field in terms of the function itself
and a good step is to just zero in on
one of the components so in this case
I'll choose the Z component of the
output which is made up of x times y and
kind of start to understand what that
should be the Z component will represent
how much the vectors point up or down
this is the z axis and the xy-plane here
so I'll point the z axis straight in our
face
this is the x axis this is the y axis
the values of x and y are going to
completely determine that Z component so
I'm going to go off to the side here and
just draw myself a little XY plane for
reference so this is my x value this is
my Y value and I want to understand the
meaning of the term x times y so when
both x and y are positive their product
is positive and when both of them are
negative their product is also positive
if X is negative and Y is positive the
product is negative but if X is positive
and Y is negative their product is also
negative so with the should mean in
terms of our vector field is that when
we're in this first quadrant vectors
tend to point up in the Z direction same
over here in the third quadrant but over
on the other two they should tend to
point down so let's focus in on that
first quadrant and try to look at what's
going on so we see like this vector here
applies this vector and all of them
generally point upwards they have a
positive z component so that seems in
line with what we were predicting
whereas
over here which corresponds to the
fourth quadrant of the XY plane the Z
component of each vector tends to be
down you know this and they're doing
they're doing other things in terms of
the X and y component is not just Z
component action but right now we're
just focusing on up and down and if you
look over in the third quadrant they
tend to be pointing up and that
corresponds to the fact that x times y
will be positive and you're looking at
it all starts to align that way and
because I chose a rather symmetric
function you could imagine doing this
where you you analyze also the the y
component here you analyze the X
component in terms of y&z and it's
actually going to look very similar for
understanding when the X component of a
vector tends to be positive like up here
or when it turns out to be negative like
over here and same with when the y
component of a vector tends to be
negative or if the Y component tends to
be positive and overall it's a very
complicated image to look at but you can
slowly piece by piece get a feel for it
and just like with 2-dimensional vector
fields a kind of neat thing to do is
imagine that this represents a fluid
flow so imagine like maybe air around
you flowing in towards the origin here
flowing out away from the origin there
you know kind of be rotating around here
and later on and multivariable calculus
you'll learn about various ways that you
can study just the function itself and
just the variables and get a feel for
how that fluid itself would behave even
though it's a very complicated thing to
think about it's even complicated to
draw or use graphing software with but
just with analytic tools you can get
very powerful results and these kind of
things come up in physics all the time
because you're thinking in
three-dimensional space and it doesn't
just have to be fluid flow it could be a
force field like an electric force field
or gravitational force field where each
vector tells you how a particle tends to
get pushed and as we continue on with
multivariable calculus you'll get to see
lots more examples but hopefully this
helps get a small feel for how you can
go piece by piece and understand
something that's kind of a complicated
expression